le grand format ce soir et ces questions
peut-on utiliser sa boîte mail ou
internet au bureau pour un usage privé
votre employeur peut-il y avoir accès et
si c'est le cas et il dans son droit
des questions qui méritent vous allez le
voir quelques réponses
anne guéri emmanuel maurel pour tourner
la page
elle a changé de métier valérie fini la
comptabilité elle est devenue toiletteur
canin et puis surtout elle s'est mise à
son compte et pote pas trop sur le dos
sur tout ça c'est que son dernier patron
lui a joué un drôle de tour parce
qu'elle envoyait 3 4 messages personnels
par jour à sa mère depuis son ordinateur
de bureau
il l'a licencié mon petit pan de pose à
moi c'était d'envoyer un petit message
de temps en temps j'avais besoin de ce
petit contact et à aucun moment je
pensais que c'était ça pouvait nuire à
l'entreprise ou mesurer à moi alors pour
éviter ce genre de mésaventure certaines
sociétés établissent des règles
d'utilisation d'internet
ce jour là dans cette entreprise de
consulting le drh reçoit les futurs
commerciaux et avant de signer les
contrats d'embauché première mise au
point sur ce qu'ils ont droit de faire
ou pas sur les ordinateurs
vous avez accès à tous sur internet ou
ou presque avec un des modes
soyez prudent et je fais appel à votre
responsabilité dans l'utilisation de la
messagerie a pas véhiculés par dont 2
deux messages qu'ils soient un contraire
à la loi et de musique à l'image et à
l'intérêt de l'entreprise
ici c'est donnant donnant comme on ne
compte pas ses heures
on peut donc naviguer perso nos
consultants vont être amenées finalement
à répondre à des appels d'offres parfois
jusque tard le soir et donc il est
normal qu on leur ferait possibilité à
certains moments pas de faire les
courses en ligne et puis de rentrer la
maison à la maison le soir en ayant le
frigo plein surfer perso au bureau ce
n'est qu'une tolérance faire ses courses
informer écouter de la musique
communiquer avec ses proches tout est
permis oui les à une condition si le
salariat des droits l'employeur a
également des droits et notamment du
doigt un temps de travail effectif dans
quête du pouvoir de ce cadre de son
pouvoir de direction pardon à
l'employeur peut le contrôler et
l'employeur a les moyens de contrôler en
faisant appel à une société comme celle
ci sa mission faire parler les disques
durs en cas de conflit
trois clics et le salarié mise à nu du
mois sa navigation sur le web les sites
visités les messages envoyés et mène
tout ce qui a été jeté à la poubelle et
qui remonte un jeu de piste qui a tout
de même des limites
une entreprise n'a normalement pas le
droit d'aller voir les mails personnels
de ses salariés c'est la protection de
la vie privée
mais attention l'entreprise peut tout de
même accéder aux mails personnels
si quand elle en demande l'autorisation
au juge
voilà